Jeff you recently wrote a book and I was
wondering if you could tell me the title
of it first
not effing around the no guide
for getting your creative dreams off the
ground okay I like the title but why the
title why the title
well it's straight to the point and it
pretty much says what the book is about
in one line so so where were you when
you decided to come up with this idea
and and was there something in your life
that triggered that in you where you
said you know what Jeff this is no more
NFA which is I know your catchphrase
which is really cool which anybody who
hears it knows okay it's a kick in the
ass it means let's get going but did
that happen to you did something happen
well I
I have always generally been NFA in my
life without knowing it was called that
I've always been you know pretty
motivated and ambitious to do things
mostly creative things and business
ideas even as a kid you know I really
got into music and you know played in
lots of bands and got the four track and
did that kind of stuff I wanted to move
to LA and become a rock star I did move
to LA didn't quite become a rock star
but that's okay but this book happened
sort of by accident I had a free
Saturday or Sunday morning one day and I
copied up at a local Seattle coffee shop
and I just started writing as I you know
often do and I wrote like one of the
chapters or something in the book and
when I was done I was like you know this
would be a good idea for black to just
like empowering creatives and what I
realized after I wrote the book was that
everything not everything but many
things in my life were actually leading
up to this book so for instance I have
been a creative person my whole life a
musician a filmmaker a writer
photographer etc but I've also been into
empowering people in my whole life I was
a music journalist where I was
empowering you know other musicians I've
been a teacher and I am a teacher of
songwriting at a college up near Tacoma
near Seattle
I have I'm a life coach right when life
coach stuff I practice something called
NLP neuro-linguistic repattern a which
is a talk therapy or counseling to help
people untangle the subconscious blocks
that keep them down and various
different ways so after I wrote this
book I kind of thought about it and I
was like you know what this is the
perfect like this is actually my mission
it's like being creative and empowering
people but I didn't know that before I
wrote the book makes any sense it does
did you share the idea with anyone oh
sure
initially yeah a friend of mine Steve we
came up with the term NFA probably a
couple of years before I wrote the book
but we come up with lots of weird where
it's terms and then this one just kind
of resurfaced so it seemed like a good
idea for a title
you